[Music]
what's going on guys let me ask you this
what if we lived in a weird dystopian
universe where they were remaking
episode 4 star wars a new hope that's
what we're going to explore today and
we're going to come up with our dream
castings for that on a segment that you
might have seen us do before on screen
junkies news
it's called cast away and we got some
real Star Wars heads to break this down
with first you've heard her speak all
things Star Wars on the force center
podcast please welcome your first time
here
Jenny lambda hi thanks so much for
having me this guy's a good pal of the
show you know from schmoes Collider etc
Mark Ellis oh thank you how this
gentleman came across the hall you know
from all things screen junkies and the
pencils and parsec show on hyper RPG the
party Joe star thank you sir
so let's jump right into it folks Jenny
we're gonna start with you and we'll
start with one of the big ones Luke
Skywalker we are recasting Luke
Skywalker right now yeah this was a
tough one but I went with Tony rebel Ori
he's been on movie fights he's home with
us I really loved him in the grand
Budapest hotel yeah dope and I think
what he embodies with Luke is that the
earnestness that optimism and that
innocence and he's also within the age
range which is really tough when looking
at this cat Tony rival ory solid first
choice okay mark who's your pick for
Luke I'm gonna go with aza Butterfield
because I saw this kid for the first
time I just seen him like pop up in
something before but I remember him from
Ender's Game and Ender's Game he's
already playing in the world of sci-fi
fantasy very well he actually got the
act opposite Harrison Ford to see him be
able to pull off this young kid who has
dreams he has dreams of doing something
more than what he currently is going
beyond his home planet
he so realistically conveys that that's
where I think guys the Butterfield pulls
off so I believe him not only is like
this kid on a sand planet that probably
is being recruited to play at Indiana in
the 1980s but I also agree that he is
somebody who would be a force user and I
believe him matriculating on to become
the Luke that we know from the best Star
Wars movie returned
Jedi you're here Wow all right a
compelling case for AUSA Butterfield
Joestar who do you like for Luke when I
think Luke I think looking off on those
twin sons with that just beautiful yeah
you feel inspired right now just looking
out in the distance music making me cry
yeah so that's a Timothy sha'lame it is
who I would form when I think twin sons
I thought called me by your name staring
to the fireplace and so yeah that's my
guy that's my Luke I'm not sure if I buy
him as a laser sword wielding Jedi one
thing I really like the genset is Tony
rubber lorry he's done a little less so
he's a little more of a clean slate I
seems like he does a lot more comedy
then yes I would agree but I do think
that with grand Budapest hotel he showed
that he was able to just act with his
eyes you know in just every moment you
knew the specificity of his thoughts and
that to me is a mark of a good actor as
well as having that fun kind of like you
know I could see him sitting down with
uncle Owen and aunt Beru I want to join
the Academy you know my dad kind of that
that that youthfulness yeah I want to
see in Luke I'm sold okay great we
feeling real or how I feel movie fights
energy boom bubbling up inside of me but
no I'm cool with Tony as Luke Skywalker
I think the new Luke Skywalker Tony
rebel Lori Wow okay let's move to Han
Solo and we'll start with Joe star so
Han is a guy where I was like okay let's
let's pick someone who hasn't quite
broken through to who Jets so I went
with brocoli from iZombie he's charming
he's charismatic he's handsome he's just
got that same hip factor I think that
Harrison Ford has I by him pointing at
everything I think he'd just make a
really solid Han Solo Mark Ellis
I feel pretty passionate about this we
do need some big stars to sell this
movie Will Smith is going to be playing
Arizona but not too many he still pulls
off that young charismatic energy but
also if you've seen I am Legend you know
not only as a great actor he works very
well in scenes with a dog he's got a
German Shepherd to that one
and you gotta act against the wookie in
this one Will Smith that is our Han Solo
Wow
Mark Ellis bringin Will Smith to the
party love it
Jan I decided to go a different route
okay and I'm choosing Natalie Morales oh
yeah you might know her from girls you
might I know her from Santa Clarita diet
where she played this sheriff's deputy
and not to me is what sold me on her as
han Solo
she had that han swagger she has a
laid-back cool vibe about her that I
just think embodies Han Solo
so Will Smith Natalie Morales and Rahul
Kohli
damn here's the thing about Will Smith
is that how old is he I mean he looks
young but he's like wow early age very
well but we don't have our lair yet and
Leia is gonna be around 20 19 years old
that may be kind of creepy we want to
put a pin in this pick our leia yeah
yeah yeah let's put a pin in this we'll
come back to it now let's move on to
Princess Leia Marc Ellis start with you
okay well based on my Han Solo it may
not have been the the wisest Princess
Leia choice from an age standpoint but
by the time they actually get together
we got us at least like three four years
so the fact that Millie Bobby Brown gosh
so that's it connect with David harbors
character and stranger things to this is
what I wrote Millie Bobby Brown as a
young lamp makes sense like you know
yeah a prequel Jen please give us your
choice okay oh that's too funny all
right I'm gonna cast Keira see Clemmons
she is one of Tony's co-stars in dope
she was delightful one of the only
bright spots in the Flatliners remake
yes yes exactly but I also like her and
this is what's tricky about Leia is
because not only does she have to embody
like confidence and elegance you have to
believe that she's gonna jump into
action and hold a blaster and save their
skins yeah that's our Leia
I love Kiersey Clemons I think she's mad
and yeah I think she's got a bright
future ahead I went with an actress ooh
again I'm trying I'm trying to pluck
these the Sun knows that I'm trying to
just break them into new ground so a
wonderful young actress Madeleine
Coghlan Madeleine has a has a toughness
but also like the sweetness this young
lady was in a horror movie called
holidays and she's a reoccurring on
Lucifer
so right beginning of her career also
we're friends and if she were to be cast
in Star Wars she'll get me on set that's
a big bonus very personal for just re
welcome to Tunisia I'm not as familiar
with her body of work I've seen Kiersey
Clemons a couple of times on film and
she is just wonderful if we're accepting
the premise that Will Smith is
definitely not gonna be han Solo and you
guys don't want to actually make money
with this crazy movie you're making then
I would say million Bobby Brown's the
perfect choice because I love Bobby
Brown and I think this she would make a
great lamb but again I feel like she's
just a little too young let's go Clemons
yeah because they're here nicely with
will mm-hmm okay so let's get back to
this Han issue guys all right I would
probably cast a slight vote for Natalie
but I do like your boy a lot too
he's just a handsome dashing cocky
charming dude thank you and that did
look like on solo to me like I looked
like the attitude of a Han Solo's right
yeah I mean I can I can get on board
with that okay I gave you your lay my
home yeah that's how it works
well that's good two-thirds of us are
happy that's yeah exactly exactly what
smooth can have a you know song on the
soundtrack obi-wan Kenobi Jen let's
start with you who do you see for
obi-wan Kenobi
okay I'm aging down a little bit because
I love her and I think we can you know
add some makeup to make her look a
little bit older we can also do an Obi
one standalone film with her so cuz
she's the right age I'm going with Gina
Torres mmm cool okay oh you guys this to
me what gets me excited is not only does
she have the range and depth of an actor
she's also very nurturing and charm
but can you imagine a fight scene
between her and Vader ah that would be
amazing you know we've got to get the
the dramatic backbone here so that the
world to get behind this dumb space
movie we're making so I'm going Ben
Kingsley yeah I'm just I'm just
yes sir Ben Kingsley yeah you got to go
with the night I can see Ben Kingsley
passing off the lightsaber and given the
whole spiel strong choice coming in with
Kingsley yeah Mark Ellis I am going to
say Helen Mirren is mine will be one if
you've seen either the red movies you
know she can still be badass and you
also look at her as the best teacher of
the force she's the best gateway to this
larger world that obi-wan was talking
about with whoa so I'm all in on Aaron
and I am reengaged in this conversation
now the one of mine came to play yeah
all right so there you have it Helen
Mirren obi-wan Kenobi Joestar what are
you thinking about Darth Vader I'm going
Winston Duke I'm going what's it do for
Black Panther yeah I think he's got that
that same quality of voice and once you
get Winston Duke talking into a coffee
can the way that fun fact the earth made
her voice actors do they just sit with
like a folder empty folders coffee can
in the Mike to get that bad echo great
yeah he kicked much ass in black panther
yeah that's right out of the gate that's
a great choice back around to Jenny you
know this is really complicated because
now that I'm realizing it's just the
voice that changes things well it
doesn't have to be for you because I was
kind of casting it for Jedi and when we
get the reveal okay and for that reveal
I was thinking somebody like Lenny James
from The Walking Dead he played Morrigan
oh I think you'd be so great in that
moment mmm interesting choice Mark Ellis
what are you thinking well inside the
suit I Brock lesner
did you know he's a great martial artist
great MMA fighter he's huge he fits the
suit very well that has a blue Manor for
the voice of Darth Vader
I actually went with some buddies
primarily known as a good guy in the
voice-over world and that would be peter
cullen the voice of Optimus Prime when
you hear Optimus Prime he's just got
such a commanding tone whether you agree
with Optimus Prime's politics or
not whether you're an Autobahn or
Decepticon you have to respect him as an
authority I really like Peter :
because he is a voice actor and you know
that's that's what this role requires I
think it's a really strong voice actor
and that there is some nostalgia tied to
this choice
you're on a roll mark alright too far I
guess to the Peter Cullen Brock Lesnar
combo let's move on to a droid
c-3po gen are you thinking I'm thinking
somebody that is kind of annoying but in
a different way Thomas Middleditch from
Silicon Valley oh yeah that's good he's
got the kind of the physical look at
that picture is he 3p he's kind of
awkward but he's kind of stiff in his
movements and he I could find even
though I liked him as a person he can be
very annoying and so yeah right so
that's my pick hmm that's a fun choice
just are I went with a guy who this
isn't his first droid rodeo he helped
work on the the sounds that went into
bb-8 I went with Bill Hader yeah
Bill Hader can play that sort of
straight man but also still a comedy
character really well he does it in
trainwreck he does it him Barry
yeah that's my guy I think it could
really pull it off you can't pull off
polite and put upon real strong choice
with Bill Hader Wow
Mark Ellis look harkening back to
classic sci-fi he's not gonna be in this
room but he's gonna be the voice Bill
Shatner ladies and gentlemen is your new
c-3po moving the voice imagine him
saying lines like bocce used to be one
of my first languages yeah it'd be he'd
be so good and all areas shake the whole
down yeah it we're doomed
oh this oil bath feels so good oh no I
hate this and I don't want it at all
yeah good no
attacks from both the all tonight and
it's gonna say you were right tell your
sister you were right
like the later I like Middleditch and
I'm like hater a lot yes so he's a
little bit more malleable whereas with
shatner we know what we're getting yeah
greatness yeah you're moving towards
hangin yeah I can get behind hater
there's on set footage of him doing
stuff on in the host SNL yeah and he
comes out and he like does c-3po like
that's a sketch on SNL yeah and then
Will Smith cuz he's playing on so if you
like join guys what do you say we drink
that haterade go Bill Hader that's good
grand moff tarkin Mark Ellis let's start
with you I'm gonna go with somebody
who's clearly played a bad guy but had
fun being the bad guy Christoph Waltz oh
just think about that scene in
Inglourious Basterds where we meet him
for the first time and he's just having
this pleasant conversation but
underneath it all you know he has very
sinister desires a uniform more or less
- yeah yeah basically okay so you know I
have your all your choices in front of
me and jenni and Joe you both pick the
same actor so let's why don't you both
say his name on the count of three one
Charles dance Lannister Lannister look
at that face the sharp features this is
for me a hundred percent target Charles
dance can be so intimidating without
being physically imposing and so I have
no problem giving this to to Chuckie
dance I will remind everyone that a
waltz is a dance so we'll win neither
Jen nor Joe cast a Chewbacca but Mark
Ellis - I took the liberty so this is an
automatic toss cool we playing Chewbacca
well with Chewbacca you want somebody
that is tall first of all tall athletic
loveable fun has a lot of different
interests can do a lot of different
things and how
promote the movie very well and it's
Blake Griffin Detroit Pistons superstar
for he's got comedic timing which you
need to be chewy I'm sure he does a
great wookie impression almost more
excited about the holiday special
following this movie than I am this
movie the rest of the Pistons get to be
lumpy or the wait oh yeah kameena who
are we gonna cast an ADA Michael Shannon
on the next when we when we recast the
holiday special for Star Wars but here
is our finalists the casting for the
remake of Star Wars Episode four a new
hope Luke Skywalker
Tony rebel Ori han Solo Rahul Kohli
Princess Leia Kiersey Clemons obi-wan
Kenobi Dame Helen Mirren darth vader
will be voiced by peter cullen
and physically embodied by brock lesnar
c-3po Bill Hader grand moff tarkin
Charles dance and Chewbacca Blake
Griffin it hurts me to say that we just
outdid George Lucas in this room but we
did dare I say I would watch that movie
I would watch the movie that we just
cast would you watch that movie who
would you cast in a remake of Star Wars
Episode four a new hope or do you just
hate it so much and you want to tell us
this how much you hate the idea of
remaking the very first Star Wars movie
let us know in the comment section below
I want to thank my awesome panel of
guests
Jenny Landa Mark Ellis and Joe star
thanks for being here y'all and thank
you again for watching screen junkies
hit us all up on Twitter bye bye